time now for CBS mornings deals where we
share items that might help make your
day a little bit better a little bit
brighter all at exclusive discounts and
if you want to start shopping now and
you know you do all you got to do is
scan the QR code on your screen you see
it there in your upper left or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass
joins us now Gail so glad to see you
good to see you too your first product
here is one this category I Endure so I
have a standing desk this is one for
home right absolutely this is one of our
big sellers that's why you want to go to
cbsdeals.com right now to get this
because people really like the
portability of this and the fact that
they can stand instead of being hunched
over you know for two and a half years I
was working from home with my computer
on my lap I had hot lap and they told
and then I heard it makes your hips
spread so I said time to stand up and
this is what happened the computer yeah
it was the computer and so if you put
your computer on this you know your kids
could take it to College you could work
out in the garden and we'll get to
Garden instruments later a little bit
you can you you could take this wherever
you go and you could get better posture
by sitting up the way you're supposed to
plus I use mine most in the kitchen
because I'm a foodie love to cook I put
my little laptop or my iPad here and
instead of looking down and the page is
flipping back over I put it on here and
I just looked to the side so it's right
next to the pot and you know if it gets
grease on I can just wipe it off and the
price is terrific we have them starting
at 49 if you get a desk that moves up
and down number one not portable number
two very expensive us 49.99 no I've seen
Tony in action with his it works really
well for him and his hips didn't spread
so because of this yeah
now I see you have a spread here what is
this yes I do this is from oh boy
because oh boy these are delicious these
are these are buns that are that can
substitute for an entire meal if you
look at the insides look at that this is
a full meal you're getting in a bun this
is Chef created they use the mother for
the pastry the brioche pastry and they
have three flavors cheeseburger three
cheese chicken parm and then broccoli
and white cheddar
how does it work you can heat them up
three ways you can use the microwave the
air fryer or the toaster oven or a
combination of bows to get that crispy
flaky and how much we have these for
49.99 what's good about this is that you
get a bundle that you can only get at
CBS deals it's an exclusive for us so go
to cbsdeals.com
Oh yeah talk about something that can
help you around the house oh I love this
this is the Kelvin 17. this is a
handyman tool even if you're not a
handyman let's say you're a diy-er or
you know you've got a kid who's getting
their car for the first time or somebody
who's moving to an apartment this is
something you want to keep with you it's
so portable and if you bought this
separately all these tools separately
you would pay about 150 because you've
got a little Hammer you've got drill
bits you've got a flashlight you've got
a tape measure and a level you it could
do all these things for you and you just
put it in your pocket or your overall
how much we have this for 18.99 that's
less than 20 dollars
[Laughter]
49.99 plus shipping all right what is
this this is
Sunday and this is for people who don't
know how to garden they do all the
fertilizing for you they don't use for
they don't use harsh chemicals and with
Sunday it's really easy to do it's
always it's already pre-mixed you take
the cap off you screw this onto the top
you screw the other part the other end
into your uh your hose and spray it
around and they're all the mixes mix for
you this is 68 a CBS deals exclusive
love it love it I love it I'm gonna get
your office work done something for your
lawn work something for the housework
and a little snack a snack after your
eyes
thank you very much we're going to eat
all this food and of course partner with
all these companies to get these deals
uh and if you want to buy anything you
saw today all you do is scan that QR
code you saw on your screen upper left
there don't even need to get up or head
over to cbsdeals.com to start shopping
right now I know you wanna don't be shy
that'll do it for us take it easy bye
okay tomorrow on CBS
[Music]